there's no doubt that climate change
will have a major impact on the
geopolitical challenges the fact that
the ice in the Arctic is melting will
open new sea lanes it will open new
opportunities for the exploration of
natural resources in in the Arctic and
all of that holds the potential of
increased tensions in in the high north
hopefully those tensions can be resolved
peacefully for instance within the
Arctic Council last December President
Putin delivered the speech in which he
announced that Russia is going to build
up its military presence in the Arctic
and of course it is an indication that
there might be increased tensions in the
future including military tensions and
obviously NATO should stay prepared also
in in that situation our article 5
collective defence commitment covers the
whole of NATO territory including NATO
territory in
the Arctic